I was fortunate enough to get drafted by
the Oakland A's but um you don't make
much money I was making 1,200 bucks a
month playing minor league baseball and
so I was kind of forced into other side
hustles like substitute teaching cuz I
had to make money on the side my first
big breakthrough came when I started
flipping couches I had seen just this
explosion of social media like everybody
was on their phones during the lockdown
I was like you know what why don't I
just be the guy they're all watching and
so I created a Tik Tok account and I was
like wow I don't really need to ever get
a job like I can just make money doing
things and the rest is history dude that
is wild